Just before we get started, I do want to give a quick plug to my new podcast,
the casual criminalists. We cover a lot of crimes,
criminals and bad things on this, Janet,
because apparently you guys love the darker stuff. Well, dark hot out,
because I have a long form about an hour weekly podcast covering some of the
darkest things that I could find on the internet from the UK doxy,
who the worst serial killer in history to that time and American socialite
murdered their best friends with a car allegedly, and totally got away with it.
And much more. It's also pretty laid back. It's a bit more free form,
kind of like a podcast would be with the occasional laugh thrown in because
isn't that hilarious.
Weekly shows wherever you get your podcasts links below and let's get into it.
It'd be understandable if you've never heard about our subject for today after
all until 2010, nobody knew even existed,
but then a routine police search uncovered his evil deeds to the entire world.
Soon, it became apparent what investigators had stumbled upon.
It was the dumping grounds of a serial killer.
Why he we'd been active for over a decade,
completely unknown to the authorities who casually discounted the dismembered
remains of his victims in the same area and got away with it time and time
again.
And he still alludes justice investigators might have a profile and a few solid
suspects, but ultimately the murder, his identity remains a mystery.
We know him simply as LISC. The long Island serial killer
Story starts somewhere in the middle on may,
the first 2010 and a small remote community in New York state called
Oak beach. It is located on Jones beach islands,
which is one of the barrier islands, the makeup,
the Southern coast of long Island. That was where Shannon Gilbert,
24 year old escort from New Jersey.
Met up with a client in the early hours of the morning.
Gilbert ran out into the neighborhood screaming for help a neighbor named Gus
Colletti opened the door. But when he asked Gilbert what the matter was,
she was clearly in a frenzied state only saying, help me,
help me over and over again. Could I see you went inside and called the police,
but Shannon Gilbert disappeared before they arrived or sororities kept searching
for her over the following months officially, this was a missing persons case,
but the circumstances didn't really anticipate a happy ending.
And soon enough police extended their search to areas where you might expect to
find the body. This strategy paid off,
except that nobody was really expecting or prepared for the discovery they were
about to make. It was December the 11th, 2010,
about nine months after Shannon Gilbert's disappearance,
a canine unit was conducting a routine search through a weedy area on the side
of the ocean Parkway that traverses Jones beach islands,
close to a small community called Gilgo beach.
The dog and its handler stumbled upon skeletal remains coming out of a burlap
sack,
which had almost disintegrated the bone stone out to belong to a 24 year old
women, but they did not belong to Shannon Gilbert. In fact,
the body was later identified as Melissa Barthelemy, who lived in the Bronx.
She went missing outside of her apartments on July the 12th, 2009.
And in the weeks that immediately followed her younger sister received multiple
vulgar taunting phone calls from a strange man who said the Melissa was dead a
couple of days after the discovery of Melissa's body police returned to the
scene. This time with more manpower,
they a suspicion that there was still more to be found in the area they were
right. But again, it was not the remains of Shannon Gilbert.
Instead police found the bodies of three more victims,
all located within 500 feet of each other in an interview,
Suffolk County police commissioner, Richard dormer, Zed,
what everybody else was thinking. Four bodies found in the same location.
Pretty much speaks for itself. It's more than a coincidence.
We could have a serial killer.
Two days later, the FBI was brought in to help with a search.
The medical examiner concluded that all the remains belong to young women and
use dental records, DNA comparisons,
and facial reconstructions to try and identify them together.
The victims were referred to as the Gilgo beach for also including the earlier
discovery of Melissa Bottomley, who, but yet to be identified at this stage,
it was in January, 2011.
About a month after the gruesome find that the first identification was made for
victim was Meghan Waterman,
a 22 year old woman who disappeared on June the sixth,
2010 last seen leaving the holiday Inn, express and homepage,
New York, the other three women who are also identified later that same month.
One was the AFA mentions Melissa Barthelemy.
The meaning to where Maureen Brennan bombs at 25 year old single mother from
Norridge, Connecticut who disappeared in July, 2007.
And the Castello a 27 year old woman who appeared to be the most recent victim
having gone missing on September. The second,
2010 already a clear pattern began to emerge regarding the victims like
Shannon Gilbert, all four women worked as escorts,
at least on occasion before a disappearance, Maureen Brainard bonds.
It temporarily relocated to a cheap motel in Manhattan where she, that clients,
she did this as a last resort before getting evicted from our home.
Megan Wars and mountain has a boyfriend slash pimp named Jackie Cruz who
arranged dates of her.
And even though police confiscated his laps offer info on his clients,
they couldn't find any leads for a murder.
And according to Amber Castelli's roommate,
she was nervous about meeting our client the night of her disappearance,
but eventually relented after he offered $1,500,
almost six times the normal rate,
there was another link that connected the victims,
all of them off at their escort services on Craigslist.
Once the media found out,
some of them started referring to the culprit as the Craigslist ripper,
although others do prefer the name, which was originally assigned to him,
the Gilgo beach killer, as you are about to see, however,
his area of activity extended beyond Gilgo beach.
So the name that became the most widely used for him was the long Island serial
killer or list.
Ask.
These were fairly convinced that Shannon Gilbert's body was still out that
however, harsh weather conditions, the search difficult.
So the Suffolk County police waited until spring and went back in,
in late March about Somalis, the original site. They found a skull, a forearm,
and a pair of hands. Once again, these did not belong to Shannon Gilbert,
but rather to a 20 year old woman named Jessica Taylor, like the others,
Taylor worked as a prostitute.
So although it was never definitively established,
if she used Craigslist to find plans, that was however,
a more disturbing implication regarding the most recent find.
Jessica Taylor had been murdered in 2003 police knew this because that torso had
previously been found in July of that year.
It had been discovered by a woman walking her dog off a utility road in
Mandeville hamlets in the middle of long Island.
This was almost five years earlier than any of the previous victims.
And immediately raised concern that this could likely been active longer than
everybody had expected.
And that there were probably more victims out there waiting to be found.
Investigators didn't have to wait long in early April.
They went out again slowly making their way along the ocean Parkway.
They found the remains of three more people.
One of them was an Asian male in his late teens, early twenties,
who was found dressed in women's clothing.
The second was a young woman and the third,
most disturbingly of all was a baby believed to be a girl,
approximately two years old. It was a shocking revelation,
not only due to the obvious reason of finding such a young victim,
but also because it contradicted everything.
The police thought they knew about LISC up until this point,
there appeared to be a pattern, the killer preyed on the same kind of victim.
And he seemingly used Craigslist as a convenient method of finding new targets.
He usually strangled them.
Men's then dumped their remains in remote areas along long islands ocean
Parkway.
That pattern now went out of the window because not only did the killer target a
man and an infant, but he also switched his killing methods.
As the Asian males course of death had been a blunt force impact to the head
while the baby showed no outward signs of trauma because of the significant
departure.
Some criminologists have speculated that Lisk may not have been responsible for
all of the murder victims found on the ocean Parkway and that there were two or
even three killers to this day. The man and the child remained unidentified.
They are simply referred to as Asian dough and baby DOE the third victim.
However, who was a woman was only recently identified in May, 2020,
thanks to genetic genealogy,
which allowed investigators to track down her biological relatives.
She was 24 year old, Valerie Mack from Philadelphia.
And the situation was very similar to that of Jessica Taylor,
only our skull hands and part of one foot were found along the ocean Parkway
because the rest of her body had been discovered a years earlier by hikers in
the long Island pine barons also located in the amount of milk like the other
women Mack worked as a prostitute and was last seen in the area of port
Republic, New Jersey. This happened in two thousands,
thus pushing back the timeline by a few more years and showing that Lisk,
if he was indeed responsible for the men of our killings had been active for
over a decade before anyone knew even existed.
Given the police kept finding new bodies every time they went out to search,
they had no reason to assume this,
this problem would only be contained in Suffolk County. Therefore,
the neighbor in the South County police department began their own investigation
just a week after the discovery of the remains of battery Mack and the two dose
and the cell counts,
the investigators went out to search their stretch of the ocean Parkway and made
their own grim discoveries. They found the partial remains of two more women.
One of them only a skull and some teeth like some of the previous victims.
These do work later connected to body parts that had been found in other areas
of long Island years prior.
One of them was a young black woman whose dismembered torso had been recovered
from Hempstead Lake state park back in 1997.
She still remains on identifying to this day,
but it was informally known as peaches based on a heart shaped peach tattoos she
had on her chest is later this, as she was recognized by the artist who made it,
who remembered that his client was around 18 or 19 years old and that she had
come from the Bronx or long Island.
Most significantly though DNA tests performed in 2016 revealed that peaches was
in fact, the mother of baby DOE whose remains were found near Gilgo beach,
creating a definitive link between two of the crime areas.
The other victim from LaSalle County was only a skull,
but police still managed to connect her to a pair of severed legs that were
found in a garbage bag on fire islands. Back in 1996,
she still is only known as fire Island, Jane DOE, and to does, unlike these,
you will ever be identified as of this moment.
She remains the oldest victim confidently attributed to lists showing us that he
has been active for at least 15 years, between 1996 and 2010.
Okay.
All the 10 victims, most commonly ascribed to the long Island serial killer.
But this is far from a certainty.
Originally investigators worked under the belief that the area surrounding Gilgo
beach served as the dumping grounds for three or even four serial killers.
The Suffolk County district attorney's office in particular was adamant that
there was no evidence that all of these remains were the work of a single
killer.
This would not have been unprecedented California's three-way color turned out
to be three different murderers who acted independently from one another,
but were active at the same time in the same place and targeted the same
victims. The Texas killing fields refers to a patch of land off interstate 45.
That was used as a dumping ground by several killers throughout the decades.
Something similar could be possible with the LISC,
but police eventually moved on from this idea is their investigation progressed.
They conclude is that there were enough common denominators between the crimes
to suggest one culprit due to the type of victim,
the dismemberment and the dumping grounds in December,
2011 a year and a half after it started police finished the search that launched
this entire investigation. They found the body of Shannon Gilbert,
the escort who was last seen fleeing a client's home in Oak beach.
If they had never started looking for her,
they might never have stumbled upon the remains in Gilgo beach.
And the worlds might still be blissfully unaware of LISC's existence.
But curiously investigators concluded that Gilbert was not among the killer's
victims.
Her remains were found in a swampy marshland half a mile from where she was last
seen.
And police believed that she drowned accidentally while running away a family
disagreed and organized an independent autopsy with a pathologist found that
Gilbert had sustained injuries, consistent with homicidal strangulation,
but was unable to say with certainty that she was murdered.
But the moment Shannon Gilbert remains a possible connection to the case,
but she is not the only one in this situation in 2013,
a 31 year old woman named Natasha Jugo disappeared while leaving her home in
Queens, her car was found abandoned on ocean Parkway,
ends our body or washed up on Gilgo beach. Soon after also in 2013,
the skeletal remains of an Asian woman were found in the South County in a
garbage bag. Now oyster Bay. She is still unidentified.
It was probably between 20 and 30 years old and was wearing a necklace with a 24
karat gold pig pendants.
The dismembered remains of a woman named Tina Foglia founds in three separate
garbage bags,
just a few malls from the Robert Moses Causeway that needs to go go beach.
This could possibly be linked to LISC, but she was killed way back in 1982.
And what is either an unrelated crime or perhaps the killer's earliest murder.
And there are more, as you can see,
all of these cases have things in common with the less,
whether it is the location, the victim similarity, or the vicious dismemberment.
However, it is almost impossible to prove a definitive connection.
So unless we eventually identify LISC and get to confession,
that will always be doubt over the true number.
The victims.
At the million dollar question, who is the long Island serial killer? Well,
we can't answer that. Not at the moment.
At least LISC remains unidentified and at large,
but that could change in the near future.
Unlike other notorious and unnamed serial killers like the Zodiac or the mad
butcher of Kingsbury run.
This is very much an active investigation with new developments every year.
Like we previously mentioned, it wasn't until earlier in 2020,
but one of the victims,
Valerie Mac was finally identified also at the beginning of the year,
police came forward and presented a key piece of evidence,
hoping that someone might recognize it.
It was a black leather belt with the initials, wh or H M embossed on it,
depending on how you held it.
I spokesman for the police also mentioned that they did not believe the belt
belongs to any of the victims, but would not specify if it had any DNA on it,
or if it would have been used as a murder weapon. Unfortunately for us,
an active investigation also means that police can be very scarce with the
details made available to the public. The leather belt, for example,
was discovered at one of the original crime scenes back in 2010.
And it wasn't until a decade later that they finally went public with it.
This is also why the most detailed profile on list that's accessible to us said
then compiled by the New York times using only publicly available information,
they said that LISC is most likely a white male in his mid twenties to mid
forties. He is married or has a girlfriend. He is well-educated and well-spoken,
he is financially secure and has a job and owns an expensive car or truck.
He may have sought treatment at a hospital or for poison Ivy infection as part
of his job or interests he has access to or stockpile of burlap
sacks. And according to one of their expert consultants,
LISC is a psychosexual Seders to derive pleasure from the murder itself,
meaning that he kills for the sake of killing,
rather than having any additional motives.
This also lends itself to other similar impulses,
such as calling the victims families to taunt them. Lastly,
the profile points out that there might be a seasonal component to the killer's
activities. And most of his victims went missing in the summer. Early autumn.
This profile was partially corroborated by an unlikely source. Joel Rifkin,
probably New York city's most prolific serial killer for a while.
People have speculated that some of the victims could have been killed by Rifkin
because he used to live in long Island for a time.
He has denied this saying that he has nothing to do with those bodies even.
So he would only have been eligible for the earliest victims like Tina Foglia
since he was apprehended back in 1993, anyway,
Rifkin might have no involvement in these killings,
but he believes that the culprit is someone who would go unnoticed while walking
around with big burlap sacks, someone like a fisherman or landscaper.
He also thinks that LISC is a local since he appears to have a connection with
the area around Gilgo beach,
where he dumps the remains with no official profile released by the police or
the FBI.
Other sources gave that to you since after consulting with a few experts,
ABC news floated the possibility that LISC might have some sort of involvement
with law enforcement,
because he seemed to display knowledge of police procedures.
Whenever he called his victim's families,
he made sure to do it from a very crowded place like new York's Penn station.
And he never stayed on the line for more than three minutes
Profile is assigned. Do investigators have any actual suspects in the killings?
Well, yes. As a matter of fact,
they do have a few as their strongest candidate is a man named John better-off.
He happens to be a convicted serial killer who also lived in Mandeville,
the place where the body parts of several victims were found soon after they had
been killed. And he also worked as a carpenter,
meaning that he had plenty of cutting tools and burlap sacks.
This role first appeared on the police's radar. In 2013,
when his brother Timothy was arrested for a misdemeanor as standard procedure,
he submitted a DNA test, which was later flagged doesn't match.
The DNA found at two murder sites.
Those of Rita tan created in 1993 and Kilian McNaney in 1994,
both beaten to death and strangled. The match was only a partial,
which meant that Timothy bittrolff was not the culprits,
but the two were related. That is how police eventually arrived. John bittrolff,
who has since been convicted in 2017 and is serving two consecutive 25 to life
sentences. Ever since better-off was identified.
He was also suspected in a third unrelated murder, but after his conviction,
the prosecutor specified that he was being investigated in at least some of the
crimes attributed to LISC. The killings do seem to have a lot in common.
The troughs victims were found in Suffolk County where Gilgo beach is located.
They were also believed to work as escorts.
And there is even a personal connection between Rita to ingredient.
One of lists cause victims, Melissa Bothell, me.
She was allegedly best friends with 10 Greenies daughter there's Rolf's murders
lacks the horrendous mutilations of LISC.
But since his were committed in the early nineties,
it would not be unheard of for a killer to escalate the level of violence as
timelines on the investigation into better-off is ongoing.
But what if someone else is the culprits after all,
it's highly unlikely that John bittrolff will ever be released from prison,
whether or not he is LISC this, if he is not the Gilgo beach killer,
then focusing solely on him will allow the real culprits to have a justice.
Admittedly, there are a few more names aspects,
but none of them make as good a case as bittrolff one would be Joseph Brewer,
the man who hired Shannon Gilbert or Craigslist, the night of her disappearance,
he would make a pretty obvious candidate.
The police said he cooperated fully with the investigation and was dismissed as
a suspect years ago, just late last year.
A man from long islands named Andrew Frey was arrested on multiple counts of
attempted kidnapping and sex trafficking.
Two prostitutes came forward claiming that he allegedly tried to take them to a
secluded area by force, both having escaped by jumping out of his moving cop.
Afterwards,
several other escorts claims that they had violent encounters with fray. One,
even saying that she was forced to take out an order of protection against him,
which he violated by calling her and leaving a threatening voicemails.
New York authorities said that Frey had a propensity to commit violence against
female sex workers. But since the case is ongoing,
he has yet to be convicted of anything.
And there haven't been any connections established to the Gogo beach murders.
Unlike most of the other killing sprees, new involve unidentified murderers.
This one is an active investigation with a genuine chance of reaching a
conclusion who knows maybe a year or two from now,
the identity of the killer will be discovered.
We can do a follow-up video on this, but until then, thanks for watching.
[Inaudible].